decide whether this guy is an upstander
or not okay
a couple people sitting up here when we
got here they said he was in the back
okay so he's got a girlfriend back there
um
destiny
okay and the girl
that was out here said that he's out
here he's always been he's in the back
they're always together she said not a
vfo but he has a history of resisting
arrest she says they're going one way
and
one way out oh so he's inside in the
back she says that and i appointed you
here
just in case
now he does have a history of prison and
stuff
i'm not going to take it i'm going to
take it seriously of course regardless
you know
that's what
i'll be about my age probably about 40.
okay
yeah also
okay
officer okay all right i just don't have
my cool chain okay
yeah you want an incognito alright
oh no i don't think andre is here
well is he do you stay here as well i
stay in this part there's two separate
houses oh okay so you got like walls and
everything in between no it's two it's
completely separate
like that's the efficiency
does the gate open over here um it did
dude but i guess
now i don't know when they put that up a
couple days ago it wasn't there yeah you
own this house no we stay in this part
all right can we go and we access
through the house through there
uh he's saying there's two different
there's different places yeah i know is
it attached to this or there's a one
back there no this is the one building i
think he's in that one he's in the other
building yeah he's in the back okay we
want to catch him he's gonna go behind
the house
that's fine that's why he's gonna go
home
i know if he's trying to get out i don't
know i just got here if you guys if he
figures that you're here he's going to
go that way
that's what i'm asking to do because i
know i already feel this way though
okay so he can't circle around come back
through here we can
you can
let me see where the other officer is
that
132 who was the back up and round back
i don't know
about that for 12 reports
this address has a gate partition
blocking a second house in the back
the subject's gonna be in the back
uh we're gonna walk around to the rear
just in case he runs out the back uh if
you could come to the front
around the block
oh
oh
does does this go through
does this go through
okay can i come around there
okay
now i'm looking for
a way to check the back of this
residence back here
okay
so
working
thank you
you'll have to go through the front
house to get to the rear if you go to
the right side there's an open door
so
did they go through here do you come in
did they go do they go through here
though the cops yeah yeah
oh go through here you guys can come in
all right
hey chief how are ya
[Music]
hey
bathroom
they let you link it
oh that's my chime online card
card
it
yeah i'm in my credit card
of the house when you're facing it it's
a red door you can come through there
andre let's go
looking for dre
do we do we know is he in there i'm not
sure i can't even really be on i do have
no clue i just got here
they're in the back right
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
fix renters in here i think
yeah you got a couple different family
units going on
[Music]
hey come out please department
he's yelling
andre let's go time's up
andre sitting up the door please
they're talking
can you open the door please
thank you
andre let's go
hey
we're looking for andre god damn why are
you all banging on my toe like that well
we're trying to find andre andre
wimbledon
is he in the back oh i heard a guy
that's her sister's boyfriend okay can
we find a father
come in and check for andre
okay
okay i don't want to be like what time
is it i gotta go okay
sorry okay okay
is
down real
quick
no weapons or anything like that right
now
okay you got an id on you yes no okay
what's your name
this residence i have access to this
house y'all came in here i've been
disrespectful i'm not being
disrespectful you're blocking our way
right now i'm not blocking your way i'm
just going to say what's going on excuse
me
what is that
what the fuck there he is hey andre
come on out
good job let me talk to him
hold on let me fucking
oh my gosh
he made me go through all this and get
six officers
babe come on
relax baby relax
[Music]
i don't care you don't act like that
yeah
relax
baby hey listen listen hold on
a minute all right let's get this done
here
yeah she'll be here it's okay
all right let me double up so they don't
get tired
you got his phone number and all that
stuff we need to give him my number
okay let's do that let's let's do
something first
breathe breathe breathe you can't do
nothing about him going to jail
just calm down
my cell phone in the car
[Music]
is
okay
is that your cell phone number
[Applause]
okay
they'll let you give me a hug just calm
down
number you want me to have oh god
yes yes
anymore yeah
no you never know in these days anymore
all right guys you were down in here all
right let's get out of the house please
unless y'all got a warrant or something
you need to go hold on we just arrested
somebody in here so we don't exactly
yeah okay
okay just stand by okay
i mean i get it and you gotta come in
here and do your thing but like you
don't need to be searching for shit
we're not searching for anything well
then i guess i agree what i want to do
too right
yes they are
and cassie has a marijuana card so it
doesn't matter if i need
1453
[Applause]
well yeah well i thought he would stay
closely and they would just trash
sizes
they should have never let him out
until he dealt with the violations
i mean he's got this one probably yeah
usually they have them
always make sure you look around and see
what we're because she got all upset
so always make sure you look search
incident with us but it's not
the clear hiding style
this is well it's for officer safety we
can search the
search
he already went to jail for the bob and
then when you bonded them out
the other county issued a warrant
because of the new law
today
you're ready
when he said he's in the other room
we're like ooh maybe he'll run
well that's what he said that they said
he's gonna run so we sent vice around
back i think everyone got excited so
everyone showed up well you always want
to get him and then he didn't
well he really could way too many people
there
swat
no
shopkins no
i've never been there all morning was
like awesome
okay i'm sure he's already heard they
had him working out with him or
something
good for you
all right
or whoever else oh you have to go up
there yeah is that your car you have no
money oh yeah i got a pca that's gonna
bring up there anyway we're gonna put
him in his car because he's gotta go up
there
she's late now told
i know they were actually he's actually
here
so that's one can he give you the pcr
the paperwork do it all right look good
luck with you let me know what's good if
you do get out okay
all right he's all yours
do you have the paperwork for him
perfect is this the
warrant okay
what's going on there's the one
before you go you guys
what's your date of birth
this is the actual warrant
you don't want anything just before it's
right here since they did it's a little
different you really don't have anything
just the first sheet right yeah that
that's it so no report on it no no
you could do like a
paragraph let's go guys with me okay
all right nice meeting you guys nice to
meet you okay
my mama
what's the phone number
to this car okay come back and give it
to me okay okay
yeah yeah go grab it and laugh
uh like that right
hop out we're gonna put you to this car
back here okay
we can do that at the station we just
can't do it here
all right uh do you want to take your
jewelry with you or do you want to leave
it without uh
what he's adding here he wants to leave
the jewelry away okay
so how do you take this one off
yeah yeah i said that's it or you can do
it if you can reach it
hey my little
[Music]
oh that was hard junior call your mom
i got one side yeah i got one off the
other ones
[Music]
her she's coming back get my jewelry
she's coming back to bring a phone
number so she'll be back
all right we got it
you can let your foot down you put it on
we got it
all right get in
[Music]
so
these guys
so what does that mean you're going to
absorb him
uh any guys that's when they uh
yeah he said you're going to show him as
an escapee and i said oh and that's a
felony warrant and he goes yeah i said
okay well that's my language
that makes sense
so he said
if you want to just have that he said
eight to five if we run across anybody
on probation
oh i'm sorry nine four two and all we're
doing four two four i had yesterday but
it's seven eight six five eight six
nine okay
all right
let's go come on you guys
all right
all right appreciate it
he said she's confirming it but it's not
ready